هي رساله واضحه لا يسمح بالعمل الصحفي
هناك استهداف نقول ان اسرائيل والاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يستهدف الصحفيين يغتال
الصحفيين يقتل الصحفيين هذه الصوره مع
يحيى الابن الوحيد المتبقي لابو حمزه مع
اخواته ربنا يحفظهم صوره يحيى الصغير يحي
الصغير الذي نجى باعجوبه وهه صور تشيع نعم
تشيع في رفح نعم هذه هي
الله ال را خلال هذه الاشهر الثلاثه من
الحرب ها هو يودع ويودع من قبل الزملاء
الصحفيين يحيى بجانب وائل الدحدوح
والزملاء
الصحفيين يعني مشهد حقيقه تعجز الكلمات في
التعبير الله يعينك يا ابو حمزه ويصبرك
ويربط على
قلبك يعني مشهد صعب جدا
حسن هذا الرجل الذي واقولها بصراحه هذا
الرجل الذي عانى من
الاصابه وكل
محاولات علاجه واخراجه للعلاج خارج غزه
للاسف الشديد لم توفق حتى اللحظه رغم كل
الجهود التي بذلت لانه علاج ايده لم يكن
موفرا في غزه وتحاول ونحاول ولكن الحظه
لكن هذا القدر ان يبقى في غزه ويودع وكانه
الاستهداف المستمر سلسله من الاستهداف
لهذا الرجل ولطاقم الجزيره في استهداف
الصوره والكلمه